-It's a party. -It feels good.
It feels good when you -- -Yeah, it's a party.
-Thank you. Welcome back. And thank you for stopping by.
And thank you for -- -Thanks for having me.
-Thanks for playing yet again. We did another fun --
-We have played so much.
-We've had so many fun bits.
-You know, the first crazy skit I did,
if you all recall, was --
-In the White -- -In the White House.
And we did a potato-sack race in the East Room.
[ Laughter ] -That's right. We did.
You were the first silly I had. [ Laughter ]
-I like being the first silly. I love that.
-So, thank you for that. -I gotta say, I love having you.
I love talking to you, obviously.
But to see people's reaction to you next to you,
it makes me feel so good. People love you.
I mean, we all love you, but we really --
[ Cheers and applause ] -Aww, you guys...
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Look, I don't take it for granted.
Look, we don't get out much. -Oh, yeah.
-So it's just nice to hear what it all meant to people,
particularly young people.
So I don't take any of that for granted.
-Do you ever get starstruck anymore, or...?
-Oh. Pfft! Questlove.
-Oh, come on. Oh, come on.
-Hi, hi! [ Both laugh ]
Absolutely I get starstruck. -You do?
-Well, maybe not exactly right now, in this moment,
but in the course of my life... -What?
-I mean, you just imagine the people that we met.
Stevie? You know, when I first met Stevie Wonder?
-Yes, of course. -I mean, I was just like,
"Stevie!" I fangirled out.
-You have to, yeah. -You know, Prince, I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Prince played at the White House
months before he passed, actually.
And just -- I know. It was just --
-Isn't he great, the way that Prince was,
also, as a person?
I've had conversations with your husband about this, too,
that everyone is kind of who they should be.
-Yeah. -Prince is a magical --
-He appears. -Yes!
Yes, he kind of -- Like, a puff of smoke.
He just kind of shows up.
-He's in the Blue Room, standing in front
of President Obama, and he's just like, "Yo."
[ Laughter ]
-He's just cool. -Still right here.
-Yeah, exactly. -So, yes,
I fangirl out all the time.
-Congratulations on "The Light We Carry."
It's another New York Times best seller.
And the book -- You dedicate the book to your parents.
-Oh, my God. -Which watch I do love.
You've talked about the influence
that your father had on you,
but also as a whole chapter here about your mom, Marion.
-Yes. -She deserved a chapter.
She's -- She's -- You know, my parents
are where I get any wisdom that I have.
And the fact that she allowed me to even say her name in the book
is a big deal because Marian Robinson
isn't impressed with anything at any time.
So I had to ask permission. I was like, "Mom --"
We were trying to get her to write a book.
She's like, "Nobody wants to hear what I have to say."
I was like, "No, mom, everybody..."
-Everybody wants to hear, yeah. -"...wants to hear
what you have to say." -She does have some great
tried and true parenting in the book.
Number five is "Come Home. We will always like you here."
-Yeah. Yeah. [ Laughter ]
That is true. -I mean, let me tell you
how grounding that is.
And for parents, it's important to remember.
Because she said that because she knew
that, as kids of color, as women,
as a woman, young woman, young Black woman in the world,
that I would be confronted with a lot of people
who would set my bar low for me.
You know, she knew we were going to hear racial insults.
She knew what we were going to confront.
And she never wanted us to get our self-worth
from outside the home because we couldn't count on it.
So that maxim is "Don't sweat the small stuff."
Don't lose it because a teacher doesn't like you,
because somebody called you a bad word.
Don't let your self-esteem be based on that.
You know, get your self-worth at home.
And so that's a powerful thing for all parents to remember.
But it's an important thing for adults to remember
as we deal with young people, that our words to them matter.
You know? -Yeah.
-What we say, how we treat them,
it has an impact, because some kids don't have a home
to go to to feel that love.
So I think about that every time I interact with a kid
that my interaction with them
may be the time they feel safe and they feel at home.
So I want everybody to think about that.
-That goes far. -So I got that at home.
[ Cheers and applause ] -I love that.
How, uh...
How are the kids?
-Kids are good. Those two. -Sasha and Malia.
-They're not kids. -Are they still --
-They are grown -- -They're 7 years old?
How old are they? [ Laughter ]
-That's how the world sees them.
Twent-- They'll be 25 and 22.
-When did that happen? -Yeah. You all are old.
[ Laughter ] When did that happen?
-I know. Before our very eyes.
All I can say is, no more babies, no more tuition.
[ Laughter ] Bye.
It's like, "Here's your life." -"There you go."
-"Good luck." -Yeah, "Let me know
how it works out." Yeah.
But now they're living together, right?
They're roommates? -Right now they are, yep, yeah.
-Do you visit them? -We visited them once.
-Okay. -When we're your parents,
you don't really want us around that much, you know?
[ Laughter ] -Really?
-So -- But we did get invited over for cocktails
before dinner because we had to take them out to dinner,
and they invited us over for cocktails.
-No, no, no. -Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
-No, you don't drink a cocktail. -Oh. Pfft!
Not only did they drink it, but they made one.
-No! -That was a bad martini.
[ Laughter ]
It was very weak, in a tumbling glass.
You know, they stumbled through --
It was mostly vermouth and ice. [ Laughter ]
-I still do the same thing.
-Well, maybe it wasn't even vermouth,
because I don't even think that they knew vermouth
was in a martini. -Yeah, that's exactly it.
But they're trying to impress you with a martini.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah.
And a charcuterie tray. -Ooh!
-Which they complained about the price of cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good. -Malia's like,
"Do you know how much I paid for that cheese?
[ Laughter ] And I was like, "Yeah, girl,
you eat my cheese all the time." -Exactly.
-Now you -- -Never worried about the price
when you eat my charcuterie tray.
It's like... -You've always said
when we've talked about the kids
that you wanted to give them the most normal childhood
that you possibly can while you're living
in the White House, which has got to be tough.
But I remember when you were saying even Barack
coached their basketball team? -Yes.
Yeah, he was -- he was dad in the White House.
-How did you sneak out and do that, though?
How is that possible? -You know, it's amazing.
You know, and he wasn't assigned to be the coach.
This was fourth grade rec league for little girls.
Right? Sasha was playing, and he and Reggie Love,
who was his aide at the time,
who was a Division I player for Duke,
they would sit and watch these girls not have their shoes tied,
they weren't running plays,
because it was a parent coached league, right?
-Yeah. Also, they're in fourth grade.
-They're in fourth grade,
but Barack Obama felt that they could do better.
[ Laughter ]
So each game, he would slide closer down to the players bench
and whisper to the parent coaches who I'm sure were like,
"Oh, my God, it's the President telling me to run a play."
Eventually, he took over.
He had them practicing, he taught them plays.
And the funny thing is, like,
it wasn't only Sasha on the team,
but it was Maisy Biden, Joe's youngest granddaughter.
They're very good friends.
So imagine it, on any given Sunday,
in a rec gym in Chevy Chase --
'Cause we all came out, right? -Yeah.
-You're playing against the Vipers.
That was their name. They were the Vipers.
-Yeah. -It would be the President,
the Vice President, the first, second lady,
all the kids and all of our details.
[ Laughter ]
So you imagine being the poor kids
on the other team... [ Laughter ]
...with Joe yelling, "Maisy, pass the ball!"
[ Laughter ] "Box out!"
You know, at the time, I would have to tell them, "Chill out."
"You know, this is -- these kids --
I think that little girl is crying
'cause the President's yelling at them."
[ Laughter ] -How did they end up doing?
-They won the championship.
-Come on! That's exactly right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ The Vipers ♪
-Guys, more with Michelle Obama when we come back.
More "Tonight Show." Come on back, everybody.